now that you've seen how to make changes
public by sharing them on github I
wanted to show you a workflow you can
use to get feedback on your changes to a
project before you update the master
branch as an example here's the recipes
repository both locally on my own
computer and on my fork on github if I
have a change I want Sara's feedback on
then first I'll make that change locally
in a separate branch next I'll push that
change to my fork now my change is
shared on github so Sara can see it but
it's not in the master branch
that way if Sara finds a problem with my
change when she reviews it I won't have
broken master next I'll use the feature
of github called pull requests that make
it easy for Sara to see exactly what
I've changed and leave comments when
we're both ready I'll merge this change
into the master branch right now I want
to change the cake recipe to use canola
oil instead of vegetable oil since it's
healthier first I'll make a new branch
called different oil then I'll check out
that branch and I'll go ahead and make
the change now I want to show Sara the
changes I've made so I'll add them
commit them and push them note that this
time I'm running git push origin
different oil to push the different oil
branch instead of master now that I've
pushed my branch it's possible to see it
on github to see what branches exist I
can choose this drop down and I can see
that right now I'm looking at the master
branch and here's the different oil
branch that I just pushed this list of
branches is the same list I would see if
I ran git branch on the repository on
github so only branches that I've pushed
to get hub will show up to see what the
files look like on the different oil
branch I can click on it which is
analogous to running git checkout Sara
could also do this and then view the
commit history to see what changes I've
made instead though I'm going to create
a pull request for my changes I'll go
back to the main page for the repository
and I could click the compare and pull
request button here since I just pushed
the branch recently but if I'd pushed it
less recently and that button wasn't
there then I would check out this branch
scroll down a little and click pull
request by default github assumes I want
to merge my changes into the original
repository which
slurries repository but instead I want
to merge my changes into the master
branch of my own Fork so I'll scroll to
the right and click Edit and now I can
change the base fork to see Bucky - UDA
/ recipes now I'll scroll down into the
right and click create pull request now
github makes a view that shows all of
the commits that are present in this
pull request and all of the changes that
have been made if I go back up to the
repository and scroll to the right I can
also see a list of all pull requests so
Sara can check this list and see that
I'd like to merge these changes into
master now I'll turn you over to Sara
while she looks at my pull request since
I'm watching Caroline's Fork of the
recipes repository I got an email
notifying me when she made a pull
request I can click through in this
email to see the pull request on github
you might be wondering why these are
called pull requests Carolina initiated
this request but she's not asking to
pull anything she's trying to merge one
of her changes into master or you might
think of this as her trying to push into
master so why is it called a pull
request it's because she's requesting
that I pull her branch into the master
branch another good name for this might
be a merge request but pull requests is
what github picked so we'll go with that
so Caroline wants me to merge her
different oil branch into the master
branch since the master branch is the
main branch and it's what people will
see when they first come to the
repository I want to make sure that it
really looks good before actually doing
the merge all right it looks like she
just changed vegetable - OH canola
I think she meant canola based on the
name of the pull request I don't really
want to merge this in because it has a
spelling error that would probably be
confusing if anybody was looking at this
later so instead of merging it now I'm
actually gonna leave a comment I could
put my comment here
commenting on the whole change or I
could do an inline comment here
I think I'll choose that option
at this point I'll go back to the main
pull request if there were more commits
I could look at them here but since
there's only one I don't need to look at
anything else if I had decided that the
change was good and ready to be pulled
in right now I could have pressed this
merge pull request button this will only
appear when the merge could go through
without a conflict so it's a nice
indicator to the person reviewing the
changes as to whether or not it's really
ready to go if the change would have
created a merge conflict
I would ask Caroline to merge master
into her branch first so that I could
see how she resolves the conflict that
way I know that when her code finally
does get added to master there's no
chance that something's gonna go wrong
with a bad merge all right at this point
you should go ahead and make the change
the Caroline described by creating a new
branch off of master and committing a
change switches vegetable-oil out in
favor of canola you can make a typo or
other mistake on purpose so that you'll
have a reason to update the pull request
later you don't have to go ahead and
push your new branch to the fork and
then use github to initiate a pull
request but make sure not to click the
merge button yet